I had a chance I'm at work one of my
graphic designers Nancy is talking about
Tiger King Pat you gotta watch it it's
amazing the story of Joe exotic so they
go and create a meme of me dressed as
Joe exotic I still have no clue what's
going on they post it on Instagram
everybody's thinking I watched it and I
said look you know let me see what these
guys are talking I watched the first
episode one night I find myself you know
staying up to 3 o'clock in the morning
watching this flippin show of Tiger King
I couldn't believe I did that so have
you had a chance to watch the whole
thing beginning to end yeah I got to
watch it you know I took the time and
look through it it's a quite the
salacious sensationalism ride you know
one thing it definitely is not is a
documentary it is just a wild TV ride
made by some really good editors so one
thing it's really not as a documentary
Wow so you would call it it was this one
of those things qualified to say a doc
you made a fiction based on some true
stories yeah you know a docudrama
it's a it's a it's a great tale and
there are some big truths in there like
Carroll Baskin killed her husband you
know there's some big points big
powerful parts but there's a whole lot
of tall tale that's getting rolled along
as well so has it done good for you has
it done like when it came out were you
happy this was coming out or were you
kind of like indifferent about it I mean
it was a disaster in certain ways they
made a lot of outrageous claims against
us and and what we do and how what we're
really working on I worked on another
program for three years it was a HBO
show about environmental protection
about Tiger Conservation
it included Richard Branson on his lemur
conservation program and a guy that was
a turtle conservation guy we were doing
the whole program of how private people
were able to produce great results for
worldwide conservation we worked on that
for a few years and then this March I
just happen to see a trailer for tiger
King and I saw I was in it and I was
like what is going on and I called
the director producer Eric Gooden said
what the heck's happening here dude this
is this looks like I'm in this and I did
not give you permission for that I have
a contract with you for not this what's
happening and you know he's he went oh
well they took it from me it all went
away i bulk sold everything i made this
special with you then I made this other
stuff with Joe exotic and I went and
interviewed Carroll the two weren't
really supposed to mix up but are the
guys who produce for Netflix the show
fire festival which really yes
trainwreck crazy thing as well
guy took all the information he added
and he made the show out of it Eric the
producer director he claimed it was out
of my hands they took it away it's not
my fault don't worry about it did you
ever get paid or no no I've never done
an economy it's just it just it just
fell off the mat when went rolling along
and I told him how can you do this you
know we don't have papers for this we
only have the original show and it says
a1 use only on the contract and so you
know it's all gonna be greater Minds
than mine that will fight it out and
decide who gets a dollar so I know I
know
Joe exotic has got 194 million dollar
lawsuit he has against them I know a
bunch of things are happening like that
are you doing something with these guys
or no you're just kind of leaving it out
because it's bringing a bunch of
marketing to you well I'm yes I've got
guys I'm just trying to get paid for all
of my footage and all of the work that
it does gathered up images from programs
I've done for the last 25 years I pulled
him off of an FTP site and then just
stacked him into a show when I never
told them they could use a single image
and the show's filled event so many
images on the show of tiger people are
me over the last 35 years there's images
me as a kid working all kinds of big
cats on there and I don't think people
even can recognize it because now I'm oh
s G my old fat and gray now and when I
had that big
two black hair and huge mustachio I look
like a different guy yeah but you still
got the look though yeah I can still see
the fact that you you're a stud wood
woman it's very obvious you got the
charm and you got the looks so by the
way do you know the number how much
money these guys made off it or no I
haven't heard a cash figure I mean I
heard 78 million people have watched it
so far I think it depends on how you do
the click you know there's a click well
you saw a part of it and there's the
click where you bend it and knock down
to 7 hours so I guess it just depends on
who's statistics you're looking at but
it's a runaway it certainly from the
biggest things in the world these days I
get a lot of contact from Australia from
England from the Netherlands all kinds
of places around the world are have
Tiger King fever so well Chappelle got
paid what Chappelle got paid 60 million
for his special I believe I think cyfle
is now getting paid like 120 or
something like that and that's for one
hour think about it this is 7 hours and
I don't even think they got as many
downloads as you guys got so if that's
the case the numbers got to be a
reasonable number on what they're
getting paid with it
[Music]